unser planet ist einer von vielen doch
astronomenteams welt weil diskutieren
schon seit einigen jahrzehnten darüber
dass nicht nur in unsere erde sondern
unser gesamtes universum unbedeutend ist
zumindest im kosmischen maßstab demnach
existieren neben unseren bekannten
expandierenden universum noch unzählige
weitere alle jeweils mit ihrem eigenen
naturgesetzen und achtung vielleicht
sogar mit unseren galaktischen
doppelgängern wort was genau können wir
uns also unter so einem sogenannten
multiversum vorstellen ist dort
tatsächlich leben möglich und können wir
seine existenz irgendwann vielleicht
sogar einmal beweisen
herzlich willkommen bei pixum science
sind hier gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert klicks um nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts ein super
standard dem vorschlag der da mal wieder
von euch kamen und zwar über die web
community
den link dazu findet ihr in der video
beschreibung die idee die kosmologen und
kosmologen bereits seit jahrzehnten
diskutieren kann kurz zusammengefasst
werden
demnach gibt es nicht nur unser
universum sondern viele weitere
universen statt einem kosmos existiert
dieser these zufolge also ein
sogenanntes multiversum der us-physiker
brian greene nennt das die super
kopernikanische revolution denn demnach
ist das universum dass wir wahrnehmen
mehr als unbedeutend zumindest im
kosmischen maßstab die frage ist also
endet das alt und wenn ja wo genau was
schließt sich dem an
teams aus astronomen und astronomen
definieren unseren kosmischen horizont
bei der optischen grenzen von rund 22
milliarden lichtjahren
doch scheint es keinen grund zu geben
warum dass alle dort aufhören sollte
stattdessen sind sich fachleute
weitestgehend einig dass jenseits des
horizontes viele vielleicht unendlich
viele bereiche liegen die den
unsichtbaren kosmos ähnlich sind in
jedem dieser bereiche weil die materie
zwar anfangs unterschiedlich verteilt
doch in allen gelten dieselben
naturgesetze in der fachsprache wird
dieser typ des multiversums als ebene
eins bezeichnet doch das ist nur der
anfang
manche experten und expertinnen gehen
davon aus dass es völlig
unterschiedliche universum gibt in denen
nicht nur eine andere für
herrscht sondern auch unterschiedlich
viele raumdimensionen vorkommen
beispielsweise wären die eigenschaften
und die art der elementarteilchen die
wir ja eigentlich für unveränderlich
halten
in jeder parallelwelt einzigartig der
physiker alexander willen aus russland
beispielsweise glaubt an dieses ebene 2
multiversum das seiner ansicht nach
übrigens von organismen nur so wimmeln
soll unendlich viele personen leben dort
die genau deinen namen tragen und genau
wie du auch jetzt dieses video gucken
demnach entstehen immer neue universen
und man kann sich vielleicht fast denken
das konzept der einzigartigkeit unseres
menschlichen lebens das ist dieser
theorie zufolge totaler bullshit als
seiner villen kinn und andere stützen
sich auf folgende annahme demnach kann
es zwar unendlich viele universen geben
doch ist die anzahl der möglichen
zustände der atome und elementarteilchen
begrenzt und somit auch ihre variationen
demnach ist die wahrscheinlichkeit also
in einem paralleluniversum das
milliarden lichtjahre entfernt ist
seinen doppelgänger anzutreffen ziemlich
groß der wissenschaftler schätzt die
distanz allerdings zu unserem nächsten
doppelgänger auf zehn hoch zehn hoch 100
lichtjahre eine riesen nummer
unvorstellbar doch wie genau erklärt die
physik diese these des multiversums
zurückführen zurückzuführen ist diese
idee auf das standardmodell der
kosmologie nach der sich das all
unmittelbar nach seiner entstehung
ausgewählt hat und dies auch immer noch
tut in der fachsprache auch inflation
genannt manche regionen sind demnach
früher zum stillstand gekommen als
andere
sie haben sich quasi wie blasen in
kochendem wasser abgesondert bildlich
gesprochen natürlich und so wäre auch
unser universum nur eine blase
neben vielen weiteren dazu der
wissenschaftler allen gut in einem
universum das sich grenzenlos
inflationär aussehen passieren alles was
überhaupt passieren kann und zwar
unendlich oft jedenfalls würden sich die
verschiedenen universen gegenseitig
beeinflussen anfang des jahres 2018
hatte ein forschungsteam aus
großbritannien mit einem supercomputer
die expansion unseres universums
simuliert als das modell dann der
realität entsprach veränderten die
fachleute eine variable und zwar die
menge der dunklen
diese ließen sie gegen null sinken und
dann dann auch auf die 100 fache menge
unseres universums ansteigen
beide veränderungen aber beeinflussten
die häufigkeit sowie die art und weise
wie sich sterne und galaxien bilden nur
unwesentlich mit diesem ergebnis hatte
niemand gerechnet doch es macht die
multiversum theorie tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen wahrscheinlicher zwar nicht nur
dass planeten und galaxien in anderen
universen existieren sondern auch dass
sich dort leben gebildet hat aber nicht
nur die inflations theorie prophezeite
andere universen
diese könnten auch nach der
stringtheorie existieren wir haben ja
schon öfter darüber berichtet dort
dieser theorie gibt es einfach gesagt
viel mehr als links oder rechts hoch und
runter und vorwärts rückwärts die string
theorie besagt dass es eben sehr viel
mehr dimensionen gibt ein weiterer punkt
der stringtheorie es wird davon
ausgegangen dass materie nicht aus atom-
oder noch kleineren teilchen besteht
sondern eben aus sings die sich in einer
10 dimensionalen raumzeit bewegen
vorzustellen wie fäden oder linien die
wie saiten einer gitarre schwingen und
je nach schwingungen werden bestimmte
teilchen manifestiert und der folgende
effekt der sprengt unsere
vorstellungskraft noch einmal mehr denn
einige dimensionen sollen quasi
eingerollt sein also ein bisschen so wie
wenn man ein foto des universums
zusammenrollt fest steht jedenfalls dass
wir wohl niemals so weit gucken oder
reisen können um unsere doppelgänger in
anderen universen zu finden die
wahrscheinlichkeit werden nur hoch sie
zu finden wenn wir dort werden und genau
das ist die große schwäche der
inflationären urknalltheorie dabei darf
man ja noch nicht vergessen dass sie die
beobachtungen im kosmos so gut zusammen
fast wie keine andere theorie bislang
und wir kommen ja allen diesen theorien
immer mehr auf die spur ständig gibt es
neue erkenntnisse
und wenn ihr kein video dazu verpassen
wollt dann abonniert am besten den
englischen kanal von pixum dafür einfach
hier draufklicken denn auch da gibt es
immer mal wieder videopremieren und
darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken wolf string theory die
provinz tun das auch university nix ist
ja ich hoffe mal wir sehen uns auf dem
englischen kanal
stay tuned ein ziel zu